foreign
[Music]
good morning everyone I just wanted to
share with you some information on my
strawberry variety update which is this
will probably be the last hopefully be
the last uh discussion on these
combinations of varieties that we've
been looking at this is a five-year
study so we've
been able to I think get enough
information out of these varieties
[Music]
but first of all as we all know that
consumer that strawberry production has
increased uh throughout the nation and
it's increased in in Alabama also
um be it through
increased consumer awareness of Health
promoting qualities of strawberries or
just
uh just the fact they're just plain good
to eat and uh not only have we seen an
increase in production overall but an
increase in the number of households
that are purchasing strawberries so this
is the pretty good thing for the
strawberry industry
uh but uh the most productive varieties
that we have are from the uh from
California breeding programs and from
Florida breeding programs and so uh it's
it's especially important to determine
how these varieties perform in our
environment since strawberries are are
very environmentally sensitive and so
but and there's little documented
information concerning the performance
of these strawberries as well as the
quality as I mentioned earlier the
consumer awareness of Health promoting
qualities of uh way into the purchase of
these strawberries so we're looking at
both yield performance as well as the
quality
all right so the objective uh the term
of production potential as well as the
antioxidant concentration of selective
strawberry cultivars in order to enhance
the sustainability of strawberry
industry in Alabama
all right so this as I mentioned was a I
was a five-year evaluation uh in uh
be planted on an annual plastic culture
system as the name implies it is an
annual system that's taking a perennial
plant and making it using it as an
annual plant we use black plastic mulch
and
resulted in about 15 000 plants per acre
and we use plug plants in our uh in our
planning we feel that blood plantings
are uh plug plants are a lot easier to
use and they're a lot more forgiving if
you make mistakes
all right these are the varieties that
we've used as I mentioned that this will
probably be now and hopefully be the
last discussion on these this particular
combination of varieties we I think we
have enough information uh to determine
how well these varieties will perform in
at least in Central Alabama we are
looking forward to getting a new group
of varieties and we won't abandon these
all together there will be some that
will use just uh as sort of comparison
to some of the new varieties
so uh what data did we collect uh we
looked at the
plant size and stolen number
uh What uh you know
what is significance of this data plant
size and stole one number uh plant size
is an indicator or can be an indicator
of yield overall plants that are larger
tend to produce
more fruit although there has been some
there's some conflicting data in the uh
in the literature that would suggest
otherwise but a plant size can also play
a role especially if you are in a pick
your own operation
uh where um
you know that we have an increase in
plant size you can have uh an air at a
time where you're not able to really see
the plants or see the fruit that grow uh
not Growers but uh
customers aren't able to see the fruit
um and so that leaves fruit behind and
just left to be a inoculum or uh for
fruit disease so it becomes a management
issue uh stolon number those of course
you know that leads to the stolons need
lead to daughter plants and and an
annual plastic Ultra system a stolen
number uh the number of stolons isn't as
important it becomes more or less a
detriment uh in this system as opposed
to the uh the matted row system which is
a a perennial system and it's driven by
the uh the daughter plants but in this
system we really don't want a whole lot
of stolen so that becomes a management
issue so we looked at that we're also
looking at yield both early in total and
as I mentioned fruit quality we tend to
look at soluble solids and the main
indicator or fruit quality the soluble
solids or or sweetness as the main
indicator of
of quality but there are some other
um some other aspects of the fruit that
play into the flavor profile of
antioxidants may be one of them but
antioxidants have a another another role
there are cancer fighting agents
foreign
first off we'll start with the
strawberry size and uh
camarosa as we can see camarosa is a
pretty large Plant
and as I mentioned this can be this can
be an issue when you're when you have a
you pick operation the
customers are going to go to the fruit
that they see and they're and oftentimes
they leave a lot of fruit behind and
it's left for an inoculum a left as
inoculum or uh for disease and it also
uh
causes the grower to have to send his
workers out into the field to sort of
clean up and find find those fruit and
harvest those so that that's an added
cost
and uh the larger the fruit
the larger the plant it also is an
indicator of
uh well it can be a problem when it
comes to spraying pesticides so you have
a better coverage if you have uh if you
have more space between the plants
and we can see Camino Real it is a it's
a much smaller plant a significantly
smaller plant produces really nice
compact plants uh there there is talk
about maybe com taking advantage of this
space that's left by these smaller
plants and increasing the plant
population but
most Growers were probably
just leave that space there so that
especially if they have a U-Pick
operation so that they can get better
pesticide coverage as well as increased
visibility of the fruit
okay so that brings us to the number of
stolons
and we can see that Ruby June produces a
significantly
produces significantly fewer stolons
than than all of the others we can see
in 2020 and I I will point out though
that in 2020 we took these measurements
later in the year and in 2021 we took
them pretty early but you can see that
there's a
with Ruby June in 2021 there's really
not a column there there is there is
data there but it can't be seen on
columns so it just it just shows you how
low
um the production of um stolons are in
Ruby June now if you were planning Ruby
June in a matter Road system this this
could be a problem but in an annual Hill
plastic culture system this is this
works pretty well pretty good
now we can see that Camino Real along
with uh in camarosa along with being uh
well camarosa Along being a large
relatively large Plant it also produces
uh
a number of stolons per plant
so this leads us to the yield
Berry size and coal uh
Camino Real and Ruby June were both the
most comparable to the camarosa both had
lower occult root
number and as well and the berry sizes
are tended to be comparable to camarosa
and then some years especially Ruby June
those group can be a little bit larger
than Cameros
thank you
uh Camino Real there's been an issue
though with the the uh I don't know I'm
talking about yield here but I'll inject
here with flavor
um Camino Real tended to uh tends to
have a reduced sugar or reduced flavor
and uh and that has been a problem in
the past but some Growers said that they
didn't notice it and their clientele
even say that uh the dairy is is really
really good Ruby June on the other hand
produces a uh very tasty Berry it's not
the yield is not quite there but uh
compared to Camino and camarosa but it
produces a pretty tasty Berry uh
unfortunately the yields aren't quite as
as high as as those others
so this leads us to Quality
um got a little ahead of myself though
and I started talking about sweetness
um but uh the sweetness of camarosa or
Camino Real does tend to be uh a little
low
uh Camino Real it has and it core has a
corresponding uh low soluble solids but
I will mention that Ruby June tends to
have can sometimes have low soluble
solids and even when it has soluble
solids that are low lower than the rest
it still has great flavor so there's
more playing in flavor than just the
soluble solids there's some other
components in that flavor profile that's
providing that excellent flavor
so in summary uh
started with plant size Camino Real was
smaller it was slightly more comparable
to out uh Albion but it was slightly
smaller than Albion uh as I mentioned
this Growers could take it take
advantage of this compactness of the
fruit of the plant by
Maybe
planning them a little closer
but I think that most Grovers will
probably take advantage of this and
allow this to to remain as a a way of
increasing the visibility of the berries
uh Ruby June had low stolen number and
this again can be a great management
benefit reduction in costs hopefully
good production in Labor uh these it is
recommended that the stolons be removed
once they start because they will hinder
the yield and so with Ruby June there's
not as many stolons that have to remove
um as opposed to Camino Real which was
among the highest stolons at least when
the stolons were counted later in the
season
uh Camino Real and Ruby June are most
comparable in yield to uh camarosa as
well as they are also comparable to
Cameros in Berry size
both had uh lower cult fruit and which
is again another uh management benefit
in management that's fewer group that
have to be taken out have to be picked
through and increasing the labor costs
and time dedicated to this and dedicate
and taken away from other things other
activities in the operation
foreign
throughout the season or throughout the
five years but Ruby June still had
excellent flavor regardless of the
soluble solid content
and one thing that we noticed in
anthocyanin content is that the
anthocyanins tended to run a little low
in Ruby June
this
could play uh play into the fact that uh
you know as as consumer awareness grows
they're
gonna be more interested in compounds
like this and berries and uh
breeders are more interested in this and
and trying to increase this or
um higher concentrations and berries
so on conclusion plant characteristics
yield and fruit qualities indicate that
Camino Real and Ruby June offer
potential Alternatives camarosa in
Alabama
and I will say that maybe camera Ruby
June to a lesser degree I think in
fields where you've got a little you've
got a few more stresses both Camino Real
and Ruby June probably won't do as well
as camarosa in terms of yield
but Camino Real tends to be a little
more comparable to camarosa even in
those situations uh Ruby June tends to
drop off a little bit because it it is a
little less adapted when you have those
more challenging environmental factors
so some points to remember uh
[Music]
plug versus bare root I like plug plants
as I mentioned these are better
they're more
tolerant to mistakes and and we do make
quite a few and uh and so it's I think
it's beneficial to get these these are a
little more expensive
and but some Growers really like working
with bare root plants and they work well
for them
uh one thing to remember is that these
new operations uh you know as Ed Sakura
mentioned um you know we kind of have a
an issue with uh
the number of operations uh providing
plants uh but
the the operations that we deal with now
they have a minimum order so you have to
be up just ask them up front you know
what that minimum order is and how much
do you pay up front some require you
know maybe half the uh the the cost the
half the total cost of the berries
foreign
and one thing to remember is uh if if at
all possible do not delay in place in
your order uh place your order as soon
as as you can as soon as the they are
available this will help you to uh not
only get the the types of berries that
you want but also the number of berries
and if you wait too late you you may not
be able to get any at all so
um now is the time actually it's getting
a little a little late so if you have
not ordered uh if you know Growers that
who have not ordered uh you know
encourage them to go ahead and place
their orders
um
and uh Camino Real and uh Ruby June you
know they have been used in or at least
I know Ruby Camino Real has been used uh
in uh
in operations when uh in years where
camarosa wasn't available uh and The
Growers had a pretty good experience
with Camino Real and uh and and to some
degree Ruby June uh to the point to the
to the point of not uh or or kind of
swapping uh
uh Camino Real or camera support Camino
Real
um
because their clientele said that
they're they're they're delicious they
think they're delicious and they're just
product just as productive and in some
cases uh even more so again order on
time uh test soil early uh
and uh provide yourself with timely bed
preparation so that you can get your
plants uh in the ground earlier early
planning or timely planning is is is
critical I think in getting uh really
good yields
so this is a list of our current list of
strawberry plug producers we have a
Dixie Green in Alabama we did have uh
Greenway plants but I understand you
know Greenway plants in Anniston but I
understand that uh they are no longer
producing uh plants and we have an
out-of-state list here but if you if you
don't have this list and you need this
list please just contact me and I can I
can provide it for you
so that's uh the end of this
presentation hopefully next year I'll
have another slate of varieties and I
will answer any questions that you may
have with this current set of varieties